foreign
the picture could not be clearer Wagner
forces waving flags triumphantly atop of
devastated buildings in back Moots
leader of the mercenary group yevgeni
pragoshin seen here congratulating his
men outside the train station in the
center claims Russian forces have now
captured the entire city
there was an inevitability about this
moment
we visited Ukrainian defensive positions
near the city a few days ago and the
Defenders hold appeared to be slipping
in the face of advancing Russian forces
a few kilometers from Batman at the
moment
there's quite a lot of incoming shells
which we're hearing crashing around this
position at the moment but this is what
it's like night and day the soldiers say
it's just constant
this battle has gone on for months we
last got inside back moot at the end of
January
every building was damaged by the
fighting the city has seen the fiercest
Urban combat since World War II
in Japan for the G7 Vladimir zielinski
who was meeting with the U.S president
acknowledged the situation was desperate
but later maintained Ukraine would keep
up its defense
we have to to understand that there is
nothing they destroyed everything there
are no buildings it's a bit it's tragedy
but for today
is only in our hearts
but the horrific battle for back moots
will not decide the outcome of this
conflict it is of limited strategic
value
what's happened here is though a blow
for Ukraine it's invested huge amounts
of resource in its defense
Russia's Declaration of Victory comes
though at an enormous cost Moscow has
won a place of ruination tens of
thousands of Russian soldiers have been
killed here and there's nothing left in
the city it is absolutely devastated
Alex Rossi Sky News eastern Ukraine